euh il y a une décision d'un mère qui
fait énormément réagir il impose à tous
les écoliers la viande pour tout le
monde à la cantine au nom du principe de
la laïcité vous avez révisé un petit peu
la laïcité parce que c'esten est venue
tout à l'heure est venu pour ça le maire
souhaite servir la même chose à tous les
élèves qu'importe leur religion je
comprends pas je comprends pas êtesvous
d'accord avec cette décision moi
personnellement non moi je le dis parce
que moi je voilà peut pas tout si le mec
c'est quoi ça et mais Jean Messia lui
soutient le maire Jean c'est Jean laal
qui VI c'est qui là qui vient euh Jean
Messia du coup parce qu'en fait tout à
l'heure dans le couloir me dit c'est Gan
la
salle fa plaisir pasême délire regardez
regardez Jean sera avec nous après il se
mettra là à côté de toi se mettre là à
côté de toi c'est parti le sujet alors
qu'un parent d'élèves s'est étonné que
son enfant n'est pas été servi en viande
à la cantine la municipalité a rappelé
que dans un principe de laïcité il est
obligatoire de servir toutes les
composantes des menus y compris la
viande nous avons fait une note disant
vous faites comme d'habitude vous servez
l'intégralité du du menu au aux enfants
de leur côté des parents d'élèves ont
lancé une pétition pour mettre fin à
cette décision de la municipalité
lorsque deux enfants se présentent et
qu'on met de la viande à un et qu'on met
pas la viande à l'autre ça s'appelle de
la discrimination comment on reconnaît
un enfant musulman d'un de d'un autre le
maire de Marignane réaffirme sa position
concernant l'égalité des élèves et le
respect de la laïcité dans les écoles
alors Jean Messia nous a rejoint l'homme
au costume trois pièces vous ça fait
depuis combien de temps vous mettez des
costumes trois pièces euh aussi loin que
ma mémoire remonte non c'est vrai quand
même à l'école et tout euh à l'école non
mais à l'université oui ah ouais tutais
vous étiez toujours comme ça ouais ah
ouais et les gars il vous demandez pas
des trucs à boire comme ça non mais ça
te va bien c'est c'est ton style quoi
tuas c'est ton kiff ouais tu en as plein
pas plein j'en ai quelques-uns c'était
mon interview 7 à H8 euh non non c'est
vrai tu aime bien tu t'habites toujours
comme ça oui parce tuas déjà mis un
jogging déjà mis un jogging chez moi
ouais non c'est vrai genre chez toi
ouais genre le dimanche chez moi voilà
comme ton daron ou le daron il met
toujours un jogging le dimanche avec
avec un t-shirt on sait pas si où il a
eu tu sais am et comment saù il acheté
trouve que c'est important je trouve que
c'est important aujourd'hui de d'avoir
une tenue vestimentaire qui soit qui
honore les gens que chez qui tu vas ou
voilà moi je Mo mais moi moi je suis je
suis invité ici toi tu es chez toi ah
non non mais franchement non merci alors
merci et vraiment toujours comme ça et
c'est pas trop long pour se déshabiller
le soir non ça va fait des très beau ne
merci Jean d'avoir été avec nous
non allez est-ce que est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce maire le maire de
Marignan impose la viande pour tout le
monde à la cantine au nom de la laïcité
êtes-vous d'accord ou pas alors
Jean-Michel mer est d'accord c'est fou
alors je sais pas quel argument il va
trouver mais bon allez-y ouais je suis r
d'accord parce que déjà il l'explique
pour des raisons budgétaires déjà ça je
trouve c'est tout à fait louable voilà
pour qu'il puisse continuer à servir des
repas descents à l'ensemble des élèves
il est obligé de faire certains choix il
a fait le choix de pas faire des des
repas qui soient communautaires voilà et
si si tu commences à à décider dans une
école dans une classe tu auras toujours
un juif un musulman un chrétien un végan
un diabétique une femme enceinte
quelqu'un qui est allergique au gluè
quelqu' qui est allergique au c'est quoi
ta classe là frère class c'est
quoiette vous AZ déjàit une classe comme
ça vous non mais sans décon tuas un
garsas un gars qui troyeuse un gars mais
h oreilles frère c'est pas une classe
c'est une école l'école vont tous les
class la même contine donc voilà donc si
on commence à
e bah oui il y a des gens qui sont
intolérants au lactose et tout
maintenant il y a tellement de
spécificités gastronomi en tout cas de
restriction alimentaire qu'on ne s'en
sort plus moi je me souv quand j'étais
jeune il y avait un menu tout le monde
fermait sa gueule et tout le monde était
heureux et voilà et ben je regrette
qu'on plus dans ce CASL et que
maintenant tout le monde réclame un menu
spécial et CER touour t de qui disent
oui je veux les entendre je entendre
Pascal de la tour du P coute assez
cher alors ah mais je sais pas non non
je croyais que vous rigoliez non non je
disais oui effectivement les questions
budgétaires une chose deuxièmement moi
je suis assez d'accord sur le fait que
ça ça ça peut stigmatiser certains
enfants après on nblige pas à manger la
la
nourriture a compléments avoir pas compl
làbas tu m pas si tu mes àou cacher B tu
manges pas tu pass tout l'après-midi
tuas rien mangé et
parilleurs pour une fois jeisre d'acc
par ailleurs les personnes de cantine
sont obligé c'estàd une circulaire ils
sont obligés de mettre dans l'assiette
de des enfant c'est insupportable ça si
l'enfant dit non bah je vais je vais
juste prendre par exemple les légumes et
puis l'entrer les plats non le personnel
de cantine répond bah non je suis obligé
de te mettre tous les inrédi class c'est
des classes
de tuas déjà vu une femme enceinte dans
une classe de de CE2 toi non ben non
mais je parle
lycée j'aimerais j'aimerais j'aimerais
d'abord entendre galdine maill alors moi
qui suis nayatola de la laïcité là je
vais dire que c'est vraiment une
décision qui est complètement débile qui
est absurde qui est rétrograde et qui
est stigmatisante et voilà moi je fais
la différence entre laïité et laïar et
ça pour moi c'est un truc de laïar
complètement complètement nul et
complètement ridicule et en plus on a on
a l'impression que c'est une sorte
d'injonction et on force les enfants à
manger de la viande mais moi à mon
époque pardonne-moi jeanmis et ben moi
j'avais des des amis qui mangeait pas de
viande qui mangeait cacher qui voilà et
il y avait pas de problème et et du coup
on leur imposait pas de manger de la VI
ça veut dire quoi on balance un bout de
viande et on dit tu dois Mang pas tu le
laisses dans laassette a plein de choses
que je pas je la dans
la tu vois bien que le maire quand il
fait cette sortie là pourquoi il parle
que
des j'ai trouvé ça très stigmatisant ex
l'islamophobie scouvert de laïcité je
désolé jeis désolé faut faut dire la
vérité quand on voit le profil de la
meress c'est clairement de
l'islamo islamophobie souvert non mais
j'ai regardé son profil Linkedin j'ai
pas capté le nom j'ai regardé le détail
et le parti politique
qui
rtion esters Dr
R hisire quand un homme on dit que c'est
une femme quand il est di droit tu dis r
c'est facile d'écrire l'histoire mais
non mais écoute j'ai pas regardé son nom
parce que je m'en fous de savoir qui est
cette personne j'ai regardé son CV m
c'est méchant Méch je voulais savoir je
voulais savoir quelles étaient ses
opinions politiques c'est ça qui
m'intéress connais et ben voilà et ben
ses opinions politiques c'est que c'est
un homme que il a le droit d'être de de
il a droit d'être d'extrême droite il y
a pas de problème mais quand quand on
regarde après là clairement la la
décision c'est pas pour faire chier
autres des autres personnes que les
musulmans donc moi je suis désolé pour
moi c'est de
l'islamophobie une catégorie person de
gens jeis que tu nous donnes ton avis
dans un instant Jean déjà en en trois
mots qu'est-ce que tu peux dire déjà ben
moi je je m'interroge sur les les gens
qui ont réagi à cette décision du maire
alors Gill Vernais il est colère les
gens les gens qui ont réagi à cette
décision négativement ce sont
effectivement certains musulmans non
mais localement dans dans l'opinion
publique sont certains
musul
cision du
ma la décision de ce maire n'est pas
islamophobe au
contraire la décision mais arrêtez avec
votre intolérance
là intolérance GL non exactement ouais
moi ce que je veux ce que je veux dire
si vous voulez c'est que pourquoi ce
problème se pose aujourd'hui il ne se
posait pas il y a 30 ou 40 ans pourquoi
il y a 30 ou 40
ans il y a deux choses a de choses il y
a deux choses la
prière vous lui répondrez dans un
instant
j'ai rien dit
encore c'estis ce que tu vas dire vous
m'avez agressé voilà vous l'z tu l'as
agressé tu l'aimes bien tu l'aimes bien
moi je l'aime bien mais lui c'est un
haineux donc il vous il vous dira qu'il
ne m'aime pas il y a un maire le maire
de Marignane qui est divers droite
encore vérifié qui impose la viande pour
tout le monde à la cantine au nom de la
laïcité êtes-vous d'accord ou pas on
verra le sondage dans un instant bien
entendu les chériis Gill verdz n'est pas
d'accord pourquoi j'ai lu le témoignage
d'une petite fille de 6 ans qui est à la
cantine là-bas et qui a dit à ses
parents on m'a mis du porc dans mon
assiette aujourd'hui papa maman je n'ai
pas pu manger et la maman lui a répondu
mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ma fille
je suis désolé pourtant la mère lui a
dit mais on paye pourtant je te promets
on a payé ton repas vous rendez compte
la petite désespérée parce que on
mélange le porc avec d'autres aliments
donc il y a des gens par exemple pour
moi je ne peux pas manger la vous
déformez le propos du maire la décision
du ma c'est la viande il a pas il a pas
dit il aurait dit t les tout toutes les
semaines vous allez avoir des repas au
pied de porc là on aurait compris que
c'est une provocation c'est pas ce qu'il
a dit il a dit il a dit de la viande je
trouve ça absolument incroyable une
époque à une période à une époque où le
pouvoir d'achat des Français estant en
Berle où beaucoup de gens ne peuvent pas
manger de viande justement l'école
française l'école publique française
propose aux enfants de tout manger y
compris de la viande et on trouve encore
à se plaindre mais dans quel pays
vivez-vous vous avez vu l'état de l'état
du reste du monde ça c'est la première
chose la deème chose c'est vous dites
que ce ma est d'extrême droite non ce
maire est juste d'extrême France il veut
maintenir l'idée de la France le
problème le problème c'est qu'en France
vous vous rendez compte que vous dites
que ce mare discrimine mais qui
discrimine est-ce qu'on va demander aux
élèves à chacun des élèves qui est
musulman et qui ne l' pas comment est-ce
qu'on calcule le nombre de repas comment
dirais-je comm communauta ou musulmanans
qu'on va servir à
l'école non mais mais justement les
Juifs ne posent pas de problème madame
les Juifs ne réclament pas attendez Ju
ça fait 1000 an qu'ils sont en France
ils on jamais réclamé à l'école publique
des repas
sub qui m pas
la plus
musul question non mais la question qui
question la question qui se pose de
manière calme la question qui se pose
c'est pourquoi il y a 30 ou 40 ans nous
n'avions pas ce type de revendication et
pourquoi elles émergent
aujourd'hui pour de raison pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que vous avez une
immigration massive oh là là don une
majorité est musulmane ça c'est la
première chose et la deuxième chose
c'est dans les assiettes pour les
stigmatiser pour le dire pour faire pour
l'affire courte il y avait pas autant de
musulmans dans les années 80 qu'il en a
aujourd'hui donc à un moment le nombre
fait effectivement office de
revendication la deuxième chose c'est
que l'islam d'aujourd'hui en France
n'est pas l'islam des années 80
aujourd'hui l'islam de France il est
traversé par des courants radicaux des
courants islamistes qui eux sont dans
ces
revendications problème le le maire dit
quelque chose de très simple il dit moi
je ne dis c'est quand même incroyable
que un maire qui propose le même repas
pour tout le
monde vous l'accusez de discrimination
rappelez-vous que quand Robert quand
Robert Ménard à Bézier avait fait des
statistiques pour savoir combien de
pourcentage d'élèves musulmans il y
avait dans les classes vous vous aviez
hurlé à la mort en disant il discrimine
il fait du racisme là il ne il il ne
prévoit pas pour mettre du porc pour que
les Juifs mus mettre de la VI et ceux
qui veulent pas manger qu' ne mangent
pas c'est tout il a a des élèves a des
élèves qui mangent
paspinard enant Ju et sans enfants musul
voulez en France il y a une identité
française à laquelle il est demandé aux
gens de de se de se
conformer voilà c'est tout donc si vous
êtes pas d'accord avec ça pas de
problème vous vous vous vous faites vos
repas ailleurs mais vous imposez pas vos
spécificités et vos revendications
alimentaires au sein de l'espace public
dont l'école fait partie et végétarien
on a le droit ou pas les végétariens
c'est maisendez les végétariens la loi
l'impose je sais pas si vous savez mais
une fois par semaine la loi impose un
repas par semaine
végéarien la vi alors moi j'ai une
question à vous poser le jour où c'est
un repas végétarien est-ce qu'on peut
avoir des revendications de viandard qui
disent on veut de la viande non c'est
très bien mais il y a un choix on peut
faire de plats on pas on est pas
complètement débile on peut faire de
plats moi à mon époque il y avait deux
plats ça vous paraî dingue quand vous
parlez de comment Mang il y a 30 ans il
a ans il y avait de plats parce y a 30
ans les chos absolument provoquer des
gens qui sont différents de vous mais
qui se sont provoqués mais c'est là là
c'est vous vous tentez vous tentez de
justifier vous tentez de justifier le
fait que de mettre de la viande c'est
pas autre chose que juste de la
provocation c'est de la provocation
fin la
prov Provo cel ridicule c'est même
ridicule parce que c'est du gâ
alimentaire j'end parce il est d'accord
avec c'estah oui parce que excuse-moi
parce que moi je me rappelle
VI mainant le vivre on VI ens chacun de
son cté a des règles chacun différent et
chacun va pas emmerder l'autre chacun
reste dans son coin parce que si on suit
ton ton exemple g il faut respecter à ce
toutes les toutes
les les croyances et C donc tu j'imagine
pour que la piscine soit interdite aux
hommes certains
jours une assiette mélang les enfants
musulans puiss pas manger mais vousêtes
stup mê principe du même
principe pas
comprig la pis les
jours est OIG de
Mang de prendit comme
prétexte religion musulz courage au dire
vous AZ problème
mus
attendez arrêtez arrtez
der de rour dans le dos faut assumer ce
qu'on dit c'est tout arrête arrê vivre
ensemble c'est discriminant de dire on
est pour le vivre ensemble mais non mais
vous avez même pas justif tu
disais'est-ce qu'on s' BR toi ta piscine
et ta piscine tu pas sujet avec ta
piscine c'est quoi le rapport il a
raison Guillaume manger c'est une
nécessité nager c'est pas une nécessité
tous les Français vont pas à la piscine
école tu vas la piscine moi je jamais
all la piscine à l'école que tu r les
gars c'est pas c'est c'est pas vital
d'aller à la piscine mais non c'est
obligatoire mais c'est quand même un vra
semblable c'est quand même un
vraisemblable c'est quand même un
vraisemblable de retourner l'argument
donc nous on est accusé d'islamophobie
simplement parce qu'on veut appliquer le
principe de laïcité tel qu'il s'applique
en France depuis 1905 en revanche ceux
qui refusent la manière dont nous
mangeons eux sont pas francophobes mais
non mais vous voulez gâcher de la
nourriture ce que vous voulez faire
c'est de voir des enfants jeter leur
viande alors qu'il y en a qui crèvent de
faim
[Musique]
qui refusent
notreç ref façon d'être et notre faç de
vivre sont des francoph
pas je
t'exque juste être logique 2
minutes on est dans un pays où il y a
plein de religions par ex Mo je respecte
la religion Mo je mange
pas je mange pas de viande comment je
fais moi si j'étais à la cantine Mar m
qu mange pas de la
journée ça ça je vais te dire pour moi
c'est une très mauvaise
idéuseaise idé je veux dire le fait de
respecter la religion c'est une chose le
fait de ne pas vouloir que les instition
le fait de ne pas vouloir que les
institutions publiques dont l'école soit
la caisse de
résonance juste me permettre une seule
minute vous dévlopper il y a un contexte
le contexte c'est que en
àéord
lesendationsig pas disparu elles se sont
diversifié donc en fait il faut juger le
contexte il y a des agressions il y a
des
agressions revendationsimentair
rendation
vestimair 5 jeoudrais qu'on VO le sonage
s'il vous plaît PL 53 je vrais qu'on
voit le sondage s'il vous plaît les chér
oui 48% 51 % c'est c'est plus mitigé que
que sur le plate agression de faire ça